Dunning surprise one it's stunning
surprise too I'm gonna spend a little
time this evening with examples of
stunning surprise one in stunning
surprise to now these this is my my name
my my title for these key moments you
probably know them as it they happen at
the end of Act one and at the end of Act
two they are the biggest reversals in
your entire story and you need to know
where you're going for them upfront you
need to know soon plan it because
sometimes you have to work on them to
really get them juicy and big I used the
words what is it Syd field I think said
it was the first plot points one and two
that's it that's what he called it and
even Joseph Campbell said it's crossing
the first threshold was you know
stunning surprise one all of which is
true and all of which is great but I
think those are abstract terms and I
prefer terms that are not abstract even
if they're a bit over the top like
stunning surprise because that should be
the impact of that moment that you are
creating for your audience really
impactful it should be emotional visible
and very impactful on the hero okay
we're going to get to that just right
away here and of this first order of
business and in what you're lining up
you also need to decide early on you
know before you start writing script
pages weight on script pages because
once you write script pages it gets
harder and harder to throw them away
but we'll get on that you need to know
where the beginning goes where are you
going to start you know where it ends
you know approximately what some of the
big moments will be who is doing what to
whom the nature of the conflict now
where do you start because you can still
blow it there too you know if you start
too soon you know if you start too late
even by a couple of scenes you push it
because you want to get it moving and
rolling you haven't given your audience
enough time to connect emotionally with
your hero that's really important that
stuff that happens upfront and unless
it's an action movie you know it was a
James Bond or something like that which
always starts his ordinary world yeah is
running and chasing and shooting I mean
that's what he does so okay that's his
ordinary world and you begin there but
you have to give your audience a few
moments some scenes for them to connect
emotionally with your hero before you
can really get rolling and have them
come along for the ride and I've seen a
number of European films British films
for some reason specifically not all of
them but I've seen them start way too
early and they can go on for 20 minutes
or so there's there was one called
a layer cake it was that it's a great
gangster movie but I don't know if your
eyes I remember the beginning it just is
it lays there I mean they're just
talking and hanging out and it goes on
and on and on and you're waiting for the
movie to start no picking your your
beginning I mean yes your beginning the
beginning is really important after that
you got three acts and you I think it's
helpful to view your three acts or think
of them as three worlds and that's why I
broke it down this way by by way of
example Act one traditionally is called
the ordinary world or the hero's life
yesterday what the hero's life has been
like up to very close to but not past
just before this kicks in what you're
doing the ordinary world in act one
after the inciting incident the hero
will have a general goal a general goal
in act one of an ordinary world for
instance I'm gonna use Shrek here in
just a second as an example but the
ordinary world of Shrek how many of you
have
not seeing Shrek okay I figured that
would be the case what I mentioned these
and I use them as examples please jot
down the titles of these movies you
really it is well worth your time and
effort to get these films and make time
to spend time with them and view them
they I pick them because there are
really good examples of one thing or
another but Shrek
is an ogre who lives in a swamp and he's
happy he thinks before character growth
but then Lord Farquaad drives all these
fairytale creatures into his swamp and
all of a sudden he just is going nuts
he's got to get rid of these fairytale
creatures because he wants to be left
alone in his swamp that is his general
goal of act 1 and he marches off to do
Locke right to find Lord Farquaad Adam
and he gets rid of them this is all act
1 stuff it is the hero pursuing a
general goal and then something happens
at the end of act 1 to drop the curtain
on that and raise the curtain
immediately on act 2 where now the goal
has become highly specific that's highly
specific and it's it's often called the
special world act 2 because it is a
world that the hero has never
experienced before by the nature of the
circumstances sometimes it's a physical
difference but a lot of the times it's
just I mean like if it's a real-life
contemporary thing you know it's still
in Manhattan but what the hero is now
facing makes it incredibly different and
special and life-or-death ish in act 2
and then act 2 the hero forms a plan and
pursues the plan throughout act 2
cobbling it together as it gets keeps
getting torn apart and then as at the
climax of act 2 as you roll in the
stunning surprise to the plan gets
totally blown out of the wall
and destroyed and all of a sudden there
is no plan it's the biggest reversal in
the entire movie and then that throws
the hero into act 3 where they must
improvise there is no longer any plan
but the best I think really useful way
to see your three acts is this is
adolescence this is your hero's
adolescence I don't care how old they
are physically but this is emotional
adolescence and then you get into the
special world where they realize they
darn well better grow up are they're
never going to be emotionally or they're
never going to be able to do what they
need to do to get to their goal and then
act 3 is their maturity now they're an
adult now they get it now they have
overcome some of the emotional reticence
within and they are ready to face the
adversary for all the marbles I break
one down here as as an example okay this
is collateral I don't mean to nail
people but how many of you have not seen
collateral oh okay good it's okay
write it down okay this is a thriller
actually a relatively big-budget
American thriller that was a hit all
over it got some CAD imme Awards - I do
believe yeah there's a lot to study
there in fact we may we may be looking
at it ourselves later on in the class
okay the hero is a one hero movie and
the hero is max max the cab driver
ordinary max but in act 1 his ordinary
world he has been planning and dreaming
of starting his own limo company for 12
years which you know he doesn't get the
fact that that's ridiculous that he
should have launched it years ago but
he's afraid to take that risk the plans
got to be perfect
so basically the underlying problem
emotionally that
max has is he has no courage then
stunning surprise one happens and all of
a sudden boom rear-end over teakettle he
flies into Act two and he's been
kidnapped by a hit man being forced to
drive him around for the rest of the
night as he kills people and all of a
sudden the lack of courage thing becomes
the month of the monstrosity stumbling
block between Max and being alive by
tomorrow morning if he doesn't get the
guts to do something to confront this
killer and take the risk on concomitant
and all that he's not gonna live the
night so now there are reasons where
he's better started growing up fast and
he does and it's really great by the
time he gets to act three believably the
arc is so beautiful the character growth
arc and believably in act three max
becomes a genuine hero you know not a
super hero but he's fighting the bad guy
because he's trying to save the woman
you'll see you'll see but that's another
way of looking at it and as an example
of basic structure that particular film
okay inciting incident these are the
dramatic tentpoles
acts one two three and that did the
whole point is they need to keep rising
you know they have to or you're gonna
lose your audience they can't just float
along two main things happen in act 1
the inciting incident and stunning
surprise one which ends the act there's
some of these things I'm not going to go
into tonight but the inciting incident a
lot of people mix up the inciting
incident with stunning surprise one and
you will talk about that going forward
and we'll see a lot of examples but for
instance the inciting incident for et
the extra-terrestrial most of you I'm
sure have seen et that's why I'd like to
take
examples from a few years ago assuming
that most of you have seen these things
what is the inciting incident of ET the
extra-terrestrial any thoughts
hmm yes yep yes yes it comes to that but
first yes well we're not in the shed but
close real close yeah the thing is a lot
of people have said that well it's it's
it's when ET is left behind and a
spaceship takes off that launches this
story the definition for the inciting
incident is it begins this story and no
other well it's not that's not the
moment because number one ET is not the
hero as you know many of you have
already nailed ET is not the hero ET is
what's called the endangered innocent
Elliot the boy is the hero and the
inciting incident that starts all of
this is when the the thing in the shed
and all this and he goes off looking for
something strange in in the high grass
and the weeds and they open Louise and
they see each other face to face for the
first time inches apart and they're both
terrified and scream and turn and run
around and run away
that's the inciting incident for ET
because then from that point on Eliot is
obsessed with finding that wonderful
strange-looking puppy dog and making
making that his pet and there's the soul
in terms of the character growth arc he
keeps talking about ET as if he was a
puppy dog and then stunning surprise one
all of a sudden when he asks ET where do
you come from and all the globs of
play-doh rise and with power of mind he
is showing him things in the air
and you know pointing at different
planets and stuff like that and at that
moment and that's why I think of what he
says what Elliot says is of all the
things he could possibly say he says oh
no in other words what he had was all
wrong his assumption about e8e this is
not a dog this is the smartest most
advanced incredibly powerful creature
currently on the face of the earth
that's what he's got himself into
and that takes Elliot kicks him you know
rear end over teakettle into the second
act where the focused goal becomes get
that creature home save his life and get
him home so there's one example okay
that's the nature of the inciting
incident studying surprise well let's
see what's next
yeah okay stunning surprise these are
the basic factors of the stunning
surprise but usual usually there's
wiggle room here folks but usually 25 to
35 minutes it usually depends on how
long the movie is if the movie is two
hours 20 minutes you know it can be 44
minutes into the movie it depends 25 to
35 minutes into the movie it must happen
to the hero and it takes place in an
instant it's one of those it's not a
scene that develops and reveals it takes
place in an instant it shocks and
surprises the hero and us and the
audience and it presents what the
storyline is going to be about just like
eat Elliot when he gets you know kicked
into the second act it very quickly
becomes apparent that he knows and we
know the storyline is going to be about
saving et all right okay this is from
this is from get out that this amazing
film an amazing launch of careers here
it really was but that is kind of the
moment
of stunning surprise it is frequently
eyes large mouths open it is a true
shock it has to be a shock to the hero
going in okay here's an example so Shrek
has gone off he's really ticked off
about the fairy tale creatures and he
storms off to go find Lord Farquaad he
goes to do Locke nobody's in the town
and then he hears people cheering in the
arena inside the palace so he heads in
there to find why is this hmm there's
some sort of contest about to take place
and Annie sees Lord Farquaad up on top
of his draperies or whatever and the
Shrek being Shrek he's not afraid of
anything or anyone he just goes barging
on in there to take his complaint to
Lord Farquaad get rid of the fairy tale
creatures but remember as soon as Lord
Farquaad sees him he says oh that
gruesome ogre how horrible how ugly new
plan the knight who kills the ogre will
be champion of course shrek is
completely unfazed
because whoa can't we discuss this over
a pint whatever it was and so all the
knights come after Shrek and shrek turns
it into a very comical sequence very
nice and a perfect climactic action
sequence to end an act ax rises even Act
one you rise to a climax and then II Act
two rises to a bigger climax there has
to be a climax to the act
and the audience is having a great time
they're cheering him on and never the
ladies that give him the chair the
reference is the references to
professional wrestling and all that kind
of stuff one by one and three by three
he dispenses knocks out all the guards
and then the people are cheering and
Shrek is having a great time and he's
not eating it up and so his donkey
donkeys proud too but then suddenly a
reversal bunch of crossbows get cocked
and pointed at them that changes the
situation oops and then the captain of
guard says the Lord Farquaad
you know shall I give the order sir hmm
being the consummate politician that all
schmucky authoritarian czar he says wait
I got a better plan and he gives the
audience what they want
people of Duloc I give you your champion
what oh say what there's the look it is
the reversal eyes mouth the classic
stunning surprise one look and what is
that done now Shrek's general goal of
get rid of the fairytale creatures has
just become the very next scene and he
and very quickly he's told by Farquaad
that if you go to the dragon's keep and
you bring the princess to me I will give
you your swamp back boom now his desire
to get rid of the fairytale creatures in
general has become a specific thing go
to the dragon - Dragon's keep save the
princess and bring her back to Farquaad
highly specific what he now has to do
that is the function of a stunning a
surprise one
and all of these apply to shrek 25 35
minutes into the movie I believe it
happens at 26 minutes must happen to the
hero always always must and it does
takes place in an instant
I give you your champion huh yes it
takes place in an instant shocks and
surprises of the hero heavens and
heavens yes and presents what the
storyline will be this stunning surprise
one does all of it fulfills all the
requirements okay here's another one
just one more for sunny surprise one
okay cab driver max is a sweet guy and
very sympathetic on a number of levels
and he's our know he's one of the most
time accurate cab drivers anybody has
ever met his cab is immaculately cleaned
this is something else about your hero
whatever they do you know a nuclear
physicist - a cab driver make them tops
at it they have to be highly skilled in
what it is they do now I don't care what
it is that they do yeah I don't on all
levels it's it's a subtle thing but it's
really important they can't just be a
screw-up schlub you're not gonna hold an
audience that way okay so another guy
has gotten into his cab he doesn't know
yet that Vincent is a killer but if he's
just dropping him off took him affair
and he's dropping him off but then
Vincent comes up with his $600 offer
I said you stick with me for the rest of
the night drive me around I got a few
more places to go and then get me to the
airport in time in the morning right and
max kind of hems and Haws it's against
regulations
but he says okay it's it's for him one
shift tonight you know 600 bucks is
pretty good plus a bonus when he gets in
there so he takes the deal in this movie
that is the inciting incident when max
unknowingly though
but in retrospect we will see when he
takes the deal that binds him to Vincent
and that leads to stunning sir pipe not
stunning surprise two very quickly I'm
one very quickly he says go around and
wait for me in the alley and like a good
hero he doesn't waste any time the hero
should always be doing something so he
uses the wait time to eat his lunch and
look at need to turn this bit and look
at his catalogs for the cars he's going
to take on lease for his limo service
he's been doing this for 12 years he
hasn't launched it yet but as he is deep
into his reverie out of nowhere kaboom
something big and squishy hits the top
of his cab and it happens to be I keep
pointing it at the screen instead of the
computer it happens to be a human being
who is squished well the effect that has
on Max is quite strong and he
immediately goes into shock and is he's
terrified and he fumbles and stumbles
and gets out of the car falls on to the
ground crawls away trying to make sense
of it
this is not stunning surprise one it is
not stunning surprise one yet the reason
is this stunning surprise one has to
change everything change the hero's life
forever
going back to shrek he's going off to
fetch a princess he thinks just you know
to get rid of the fairytale creatures
that journey will change his life
forever ultimately he's gonna fall in
love for the first time in his life and
that will change everything right here
he's a cab driver and that's pretty
outrageous to have dead body fall on top
of your cab and it's kind of scary but
realistically it is not outside of what
normally happens in a city he could you
know go have a great tale maybe it'll be
written up in the newspapers and
tomorrow night he'll be driving a new
cab his old life would continue
yeah it's spooky and it's big and it's
dramatic and loud but it does not yet
change his life so Vincent comes
mumbling out very self-controlled and
the max is all rattled and he said it's
wrong I think he's dead
good guess Vincent plays it low-key and
at that moment the thought finally
crosses Max's mind you killed him I
think Vincent says you know I shot him
it was the bullet in the fall that
killed him I mean it's a kind of cynical
snide guy he is for a killer right and
even this is not the stunning surprise
yet because he has to get that linked up
with one more factor before it changes
his life forever and it's this Vincent's
try to stop him from running away point
pulls the gun points a gun at him ago
and now he gets it
this is stunning surprise one and look
at the expression it is the stunning
surprise expression because now he knows
the full story which is he is the
captive of an assassin and that mean and
he knows I mean he could be seen his
face he said conversations with the guy
assassins don't let such people live so
he now sees that this is called you know
ass over teakettle here and into act 2
because now for the first time he is in
the special world of being a hostage of
a man who kills people for a living that
he has to drive around for the rest of
the night and the possibilities of max
coming out the other side of this you
know by morning
getting away from this guy are
practically no practically impossible
so now Max has faced a situation he's
never faced before and that is called a
special world indeed how is he gonna
pull this off mild-mannered and Max is
gonna confront this guy with life and
death act 2 begins and the difference
here is where is it there it is ament's
in in collateral i think act 1 is 19
minutes 19 minutes long pretty
pretty short for act 1 yes but think
about why this story is about a cab
driver act 1 his ordinary world almost
fall takes place inside of the cab this
is a thriller the movie is a thriller
you got to get something going you've
got to get the story pumped up and
running quickly not in 25 minutes know
people aren't gonna hang around you've
got to do it as soon as possible a lot
of stuff is set up in act 1
in that 19 minutes and we're gonna take
a close look at this coming up in a few
weeks
oh the brilliance with which this thing
was composed this first act but that's
why it has to be shorter and that is
another statement of the paradigm being
flexible in some ways okay that was
stunning surprised one then there's
midpoint we're not going into the
midpoint tonight the midpoint is juicy
and there's a great deal to be discussed
about the midpoint the midpoint is not a
moment like a stunning surprise it's not
just one moment of shock it is it's a
series as if not always but as a rule
it's a series of short scenes in which
several key things that advance the
story happen including them one of them
is it's a key character growth moment
and we'll talk about that another time
but now I want to jump to the other key
one most important one which is stunning
surprise to